welcome to this video playing Paloma
from prom prom prom that's not the
Netherlands there is some Paraguay
Paraguay yes got it right it costs the
some seconds but I got it right okay g3
and interesting sideline of the Sicilian
he's playing for very quick queenside
expansion I've played comparable lights
myself but normally when when the night
was on c3 and is's in fact the
difference because she look at this here
my night is not on c3 and this means i
have means to attack the queenside
directly without before gaining a tempo
against the night this is a very
important point here after before I
would have played c3 and we're
completely five now that's a bit strange
okay it's a bit strange because usually
he takes f6 and such a position is very
good for wide let's see if I take ya
then their sacrifices looming already mm
hmm interesting I take on e 6f e6 rookie
6 king of seven don't
don't see a win
wow it looks terrible but it's there
it's there when I don't see it at the
moment
well I don't see it if I'd take various
ideas taking on geez I'm Luke Bishop g7
Luke take c6f equinox 5 check at King is
seven that seems to it seems to hold it
looks it doesn't look good but it seems
too old
hmm maybe it maybe atoning maybe not yes
there is there some other move Bishop g5
maybe mmm it's also dangerous no doubt
clean h5 is also possible Knight f6
Brooke take c6 chicken this should be
seven that's probably not winning and if
i take i can take a plane right at five
of course why not why not early am this
is just easy it took me ages i try to
find a completely directly winning line
maybe this is in winning attacking d6
and d7 how to see how does it offend
that
maybe needs to take on c3 I can take d6
and even be seven with attacking with
the tech but I take on the queen young
and Bishop b5 yeah that's more than one
good good way to play rookie 5 or just
night x t6 also just good ok if I check
here and go for this 96 business and
night x b7 yep ok I must be I must
increase increase the speed here ok I
can take what the night of course
sometimes you really wonder what you
want what what was your train of thought
yeah maybe 96 or cesium I'm not sure
what is what he is thinking about I mean
that takes the fibers the only move not
instantaneously getting clobbered at
least I think 96 checking is seven ok
yeah maybe you need to check check stuff
like that with Bishop to Bishop g5 check
yeah but still d 596 looks completely
devastating to me cannot even clicking
f8 because of Bishop h6 Sookie 7 and
then probably just dye takes b7 is also
taking a stun I will Knight takes Knight
XD 6 king is 79 takes be 70 you can do
that it's not bad at all yeah I probably
will go for that his not sir start
moving don't tell me you're disconnected
in this position no there is not a
disconnected yeah well strange at some
point you need to move I would just take
the Nile with the night to get it get it
more active to be honest
night 95-96 king in 7 night XP seven and
then Queen Queen c7 may be attacking in
the night yeah then it's a nice
calculation exercise with Bishop g5 and
moose like that maybe also 94 is an idea
then intending Bishop g5 check and what
the heck is going on I you're not
disconnected right yeah it doesn't
doesn't look like it's a disconnection
but it's not moving well in this
position yeah well you never know maybe
a doorbell rang on I got no bitten by
his dog or something but it's a shame i
would love to see this this played out
okay then we need to to check it with
the width um some analysis black for
fits on time yeah not too not sure why
first I'd like to check here if I have a
96 is winning how exactly does it win
tonight taking here of course then just
gem ah I completely overlooked that now
I'm actually threatening the simple
Queen takes t6 also with the check down
and rock t6 if he goes to f7 I just go
room takes and this is deadly the king
is is just far too exposed ah bad bad
shape 96 is not not terribly difficult
and it's very logical of course I spent
what two minutes here to take to take
their okay well 96 20 wins
transposition of moves now here yeah it
seems that white is also winning here
but the other line was of course far far
better yeah let's check night x was the
move I expected yeah here 9 p-7 and then
I expected a queen move rock here then
94 yeah then this was winning this was
my intention to threaten this move if he
now it takes there's check checkmate
this funny point you're probably right
just just win see another computer says
why this winning but it's still a
different matter to to play it out on
the board what is important is to note
that a quick let me a quick queenside
expansion is normally far more powerful
this a 6b five business if there's
actually a knight on c3 that can be
attacked without the night this is
sometimes quite pointless because it
does not really aim at a specific goal
like dislodging the night and in
concrete terms it means that this a form
break is far better than their normal
something like this is just good for
white like neck and take but then i'll
take here and there are many lines in
the song in weather is 93 plate a4 then
be 491 back then c 3 takes a night eggs
and i want to lose compared to such a
line for example if black now tries to
play em yeah well neither of six is just
embed due to that we saw that but let's
say aerotek
for example even then there's he five
but what I was getting at is their white
also has this before I DMV 596 it's just
a very nice position for wine okay
thanks for watching